الان الى عالمي الطب والابحاث فقد نبه
فريق من الخبراء العالميين الى ان الجيل
المقبل من العلاجات الجينيه المتقدمه يثير
قضايا طبيه واخلاقيه عميقه يجب التغلب
عليها لضمان ان هذه التكنولوجيا التي تشكل
نقطه تحول في علم الوراثه تفيد المرضى
والمجتمع يتزامن هذا التحذير مع القمه
الدوليه الثالثه بشان تعديل الجينيوم
البشري في معهد فرانسيس كيرك في لندن
والتي تستمر ثلاثه ايام التفاصيل في تقرير
التالي
الامراض الوراثيه مثل الخلايا المنجليه
والتليف الكيسي وانتن تبدا كتغيرات في
الجينات وهي تلك الرموز الموجوده في الحمض
النووي البشري الذي تخبر الجسم بكيفيه
تكوين الخلايا يمكن للادوات الجديده مثل
ما تسمى تقنيه كريسبر للتعديل الجيني ان
تحدث فرقه فهي تتيح ايجاد وقطع واستبدال
الاجزاء المعيبه من جينات الكائنات الحيه
لتقديم شفره جينيه مصححه
ويسعى العلماء لاستخدامها في توفير علاج
سريع وفعال للطفرات الجينيه مما يفتح
افاقا جديده في الطب الوراثي لكن ثم تم
مخاوف منها واحده من هذه المخاوف هي
استخدام تكنولوجيا تعديل الجينوم لتغيير
الاجنه البشريه لاغراض الانجاب فقد شاب
جدل القمه السابقه لتعديل الجينوم البشري
عام 2018 في هونج كونج عندما كشف العالم
الصيني هي جان كوي انه تمكن من انتاج اول
طفلتين معدلتين وراثيا في العالم
وهما توامان سماهما لولو وننا وقد عدل
الحمض النووي
للطفلتين بينما كانت في مرحله جنينيه
بطريقه
انها ستجعلهما اقاومتين للاصابه بفيروس
نقص المناعه المكتسب الايتس وهو ما قبل
حينها باستنكار شديد من قبل العلماء وادى
الى سجن العالم ثلاثه اعوام يقول فريق
دولي من العلماء ان تعديل الجنون في اثناء
الحمل ليس امنا والتقنيه ليست جاهزه بعد
ويخشى العلماء من ان عيادات الخصوبه يمكن
ان تستخدم التكنولوجيا لتقديم خدمات تعديل
الجينات وتحسين النسل لانتاج ما يطلق عليه
اطفال وفق الطلب وبينما تشق التكنولوجيا
تعديل الشفره الجينيه لعلاج الامراض
النادره طريقها من المراحل التجريبيه الى
العمليه وان كان بتكلفه باهظه الان يبقى
التحدي الاكبر هو جعلها في متناول الناس
وباسعار معقوله
انضم الينا من عمان البروفيسور محمد الرقه
الاستشاري الامراض الوراثيه السريريه وعلم
الجينات بكليه الطب بجامعه دكتور محمد
اهلا بك عندما نقف امام
مبشرات علميه بهذا المستوى قد تعطي تغيير
فوري في كثير من الامراض التي توجد ولكن
ايضا في المقابل هناك محاذير اخلاقيه
واخرى كيف للعلم ان يتصرف امام هذه الحاله
يا سيدي حياك الله مرحبا الان يا سيدي
العزيز البشريه منذ تكوينها او منذ وجودنا
على هذا الارض لعمر حوالي اربعه ونصف
مليار سنه في تطور التطور اللي حدث
للبشريه في اخر 100 عام يعادل اضعاف ما
حدث في الماضيه ولكن كنا نتذكر عن
الفينو فك الشيفر للانسان هذا الحدث
العالمي اللي كانوا قفز عنيفه للبشريه
للامام يعادل
نزول
على القمر
وفكينا الشيفره الوراثيه للانسان ونتبع
جيناتنا هي الاساس في تكويننا يعني كل جيل
مسؤول عن انتاج بروتين والبروتين له وظيفه
حيويه اي تغيير وراثي في هذا الجين يؤدي
الى خربطه في الوظيفه فبالتالي يحدث الامر
الاغلب الامراض الوراثيه كانت تعتبر
مستعصيه ولكن الحمد لله هدف قفزات عنيفه
اقدر الان قطع الجيني ذاته بالتالي نجنب
المريض والبشريه المعاناه يصير العزيز زي
ما تفضلت هو في الاشكاليه هي الاخلاقيه
اللي احنا دائما نحكي الهم باحثين وكاطباء
في هذا المجال
مثال بسيط عشان كله صوره واضحه للمشاهدين
في جامعه نيوكاسل بريطانيا
قراوا طريقه بالالفين 2008 الفين وتسعه
علاج امراض
الميتوكندريا المايتوكندريا جزء من الخليه
المسؤوله عن الطاقه وكان حلها لانه هاي
الموجود فيها ياتي من الام فكان هو عباره
عن انه ام ثاني تتبرع بويضه ونستخلص
النواه تبعت الام الحقيقيه ونزرعها
بالبويضه الثانيه ومن ثم نعمل عمليه اطفال
انابيب ورجع الجنين على الام الحقيقيه
فتنتج العمليه عباره عن سير عنا ثلاثه
اباء يعني اب وام فهذه مشكله اخلاقيه
عنيفه واتوقع احتاجه حوالي 9 سنوات في
الان هذه الجذري لامراض مثلا
المايتوكندريا الان في المباراه الثانيه
بلش فيه حلاقه علاج لها بحيث نعالج الخطا
الجيني وهم مرضه مرض ضمور العضلات
الوراثيه
والدوشين طلع له علاج صعيب 2016 ولكن
يعتمد كله على مبدا نوعيه الطفر الوراثيه
المسبقه للمرض
طيب دكتور يعني كيف يمكن رسم هذه الخطوط
القانونيه
يعني اخلاقيا في تطور العلم باتجاه هذه
التكنولوجيا الوراثيه والتي يحتاجها
الانسان كي لا تصبح ايضا تجاريه وسلعه يتم
تداولها فقط الذي يستطيع ان يدفع ذلك
بالضبط يعني تفضلتي فيه هذا الكلام مهم
جدا وهو ما يقلق العامه خلينا نحكي الان
لما طلعت تقنيه
كرسبيل 2012 وبلش التعديل عليها والتطوير
بالاصل موجوده يعني ربنا خلقها بالبكتيريا
عشان تقاوم الغزو الفيروسي لهذه البكتيريا
فاحنا استخدمناها
في موضوع علاج الاخطاء الجنيه الموجوده
عند البشر هي الحقيقه راح تعمل يعني ثوره
في العلاج الامراض المستعصيه وان شاء الله
انه احنا كاطباء ننظر لها يعني بشغف عشان
تحل لنا الامراض المستعصيه ولكن الجانب
الثاني هو يمكن يكون الجانب المظلم اي شيء
دائما له صيدين يعني في عندك
الجانب المظلم هو كيفيه استخدام هذه
التقنيه يجب توظيفها فقط لخدمه البشريه
لتخليصها من امراضها المستعصيه الان زي ما
تفضلتي ممكن تستغل اغراض ثانيه
الاغراض الثانيه هو عباره عن انه انا اصفي
اني بدي انقي طفلي بدي انقي الصفه
الوراثيه هاي لان العمليه هي ممكن تحلق
يعني يعني تقنيه مرعبه كت وبيست يعني ممكن
نقطع اي جزء من ايه ونصلحه فهي يعني اشي
اشي مرعب يعني في ناس بقولوا انه مثلا حتى
من امور دينيه تعديل في خلق الله وكذا
وكذا فهي القضيه لسه لم تحسم اخلاقيا ولا
علميا الطبيب الصيني اللي هو عمل اشكاليه
اللي هو العالم كلها توقف الكريسماره الان
حط ايدهم عليه هو صحيح يعني كان له جنب
يعني انا دائما في جانب ايجابي
فلانا ننتبه انه في اشي ممكن يصير غلط
كبير في استخدام هذه التقنيه من هون بيجي
دور الدول ودور الجهات الرقابيه والمؤسسات
البحثيه لوضع خطوط عامه وشديده ومشدده
استخدام هاي التقنيه وتوظيفه
تقع على الدول وعلى الصحابي القرار
كيفيه استخدام هاي التقنيه شكرا لك من
اعمام بروفيسور محمد رقاد استشاري الامراض
الوراثيه السريريه وعلم الجينات بكليه تطب
بجامعه البلقاء شكرا على المشاركه معنا